[Music]
[Applause]
Brian Baumgardner great actor he of
course uh played the role of Kevin
Malone on the office good friends with
Aaron Rodgers on the sidelines Monday
night Aaron comes over gives him a big
hug and then it went South from there
Brian joins us on the program how did
you end up on the sidelines
uh first off good morning Dan good
morning I uh I I have no idea I I
decide I'm doing a speaking conference
in Syracuse by the way I should mention
the human resources conference how I got
chosen to speak at a human resources
conference I still don't know they were
delightful and I was going to be in
Syracuse Sunday night I had a flight
back Monday morning and I was like you
know what it's game one he's playing
it's a four hour drive we've got I've
got to go so we call the Jets we I don't
know someone on my team calls the Jets
and says I want to go I tell him I'm
going and I show up at the stadium and I
don't know I've never been there I've
never been to to MetLife uh I've I've
resided in in Lambeau for quite a while
and so I show up and suddenly they're
like we have 15 minutes do you want to
go on the field I said well yeah sure to
go down maybe I can see him and say hi
and I didn't see him coming over I tried
to get his attention a couple times and
and then he ran over and it was uh
it was very emotional Dan I have to tell
you I have been
fortunate enough to have been at Super
Bowls and uh World Series and NBA finals
games the Kerry strugg moment at the
Olympics in Atlanta when the she broke
her leg or whatever
I have never felt a stadium a sporting
venue feel the way that it did in
MetLife on Monday night in my life
that's me I'm not gonna argue you know
other people can bring up I am saying
for me on the sidelines before when they
first ran out this was for warm-ups and
the guy with the hats started doing the
j-e-t-s Jets it was chills were running
down my spine
and then we went up to the seats and you
know when he ran out
with the American flag he's introduced
I've never heard something that loud and
that like genuine because it wasn't like
oh let's cheer on our team it was like
the weight of
55 years since they've won a Super Bowl
but really 22 years since 9 11 I'm
getting chills talking about it right
now I'm giving myself chills which is
weird but it was just like you could
feel this Collective relief and Euphoria
and like he was carrying the hopes for
them as a team and a city for the year
it was just it was on it was it was a
moment I will never forget never forget
and then then of course 11 minutes later
it's like that's the dead done crazy
uh you were one of the few that I didn't
text that night anyone's number that I
had in my phone I you know some people
started texting me I'm not gonna mention
a ton of names but like because I was at
the stadium and I guess this video had
gotten released and I was there asking
me what was going on like I can't see
anything so I just am trying to find out
like what's going on is you know is he
okay is he coming back is he on the
sideline at one point
I will tell you this is nothing about it
it's funny but I was across the field
and I saw somebody with a ball that
looked like him now maybe he doesn't
look like him at all but from where I
was across the field and I
um I guess my eyes are going bad I'm
like is that eight is that eight he's
like tossing a ball up in the air is
that eight to the guy I'm with and he
goes no that's that's five the punter
that's not it's not eight
um so I didn't know what was going on it
was just uh it was just horrible have
you reached out to Rogers
uh yeah but you know he's got a lot
going right now and I you know I expect
at some point you know I flew back
yesterday morning I told uh fritzy I you
know I so I flew back yesterday morning
kind of when everything was for real for
real happening
um and I you know I suspect I'll talk to
him at some point here when when things
calm down and and maybe he gets uh his
procedure done when's the first time you
met Aaron Rodgers how did this Bromance
start
so the American Century Championship
which is the golf tournament that's in
Lake Tahoe
um this is 2008 summer of 2000 this
story is INS I don't know if I've ever
told you the story the story isn't
saying
I was sitting at a blackjack table
there's a Harris Casino yeah yeah I've
been there and I'm I'm sitting at the
blackjack table and there's guys sitting
next to me and there's some people
around and he starts chatting with me
I have no idea who he is no clue who he
is he's a fan of the office and
um so we're chatting and then when he
introduces himself I'm like oh you're
the cow guy right you're the guy who's
gonna replace spread farf here in a few
miles nice to meet you and
and their TVs around the this is a true
story this doesn't this sounds like a
movie it doesn't sound real their TVs
around the casino up above the tables
you can kind of glance at and that day
is the day that Brett Favre said I'm not
retiring
so he's sitting there he's playing in
this event he's about to be the starter
of the Green Bay Packers barf has
already retired and now far says I'm not
retiring so at this day that we meet he
doesn't know if he has a job or not or
if he's going to be a backup again or
they're going to sign him and you know
all of that stuff and you know I don't
know maybe maybe I feel bad for him I
don't know we just became friends and uh
then started playing a lot of golf
together he was living off season in the
uh Southern California area and
um ended up I guess a couple years later
going to uh the Super Bowl in Dallas
uh where they won and um well whose idea
was it to put him in an episode of The
Office
I mean
that was me
that I mean you know at that point we
were really really good friends and we
did a table read of this was like the
final penultimate episode I think they
he I think it was supposed to be the
second to the last episode it ended up
kind of in the last episode that might
be wrong
um
and they had some they had a sports star
written in who I'm not gonna name
in the script can we go after can we
guess sure okay uh football player no
wait a minute you can't it's not 20
questions
you know like I don't know if I I don't
know if that's ever gotten out I don't
know if I can do it I don't know LeBron
James no Steph Curry no all right
everybody gets a guess frizzy take a
guess
Michael Jordan no okay Satan Scotty
Pippen no
Marvin
Charles Barkley
no
Paulie I'll go Michael Phelps
you're closer but that's not true also
that's not correct Closer Closer Closer
all right closer meaning
gosh I don't know if this is ever gone I
don't can I say
you're still on scholarship here we go
hold on
I'm not even supposed to talk about the
show right now no no you can talk about
the past you can't talk about this I
don't think I I don't think I can
um
ah it was a tennis player
John McEnroe nope
Serena who was the tennis player that
lived in Los Angeles now I'm like
telling you
Pete Sampras nope
I don't know why we're doing this game
why just tell me who it is Andy Roddick
Andy Roddick was Mike Andy Roddick okay
yeah it was there and I so I went to
Greg Daniels and I just said I mean
bigfooted Andy Roddick this is
Dan I don't know yeah Andy was I've met
Andy I don't know if Andy was a big fan
anyway it doesn't matter I went to Greg
and I said is this a deal like is this
is his name here because it's a done
deal in which case I would have done
nothing and he said no he was you know
not a placeholder but he was someone we
would love to have but we have not
reached out to anyone yet and I said
well I have a friend who's a really big
fan of the show if you're looking for a
sports guy I think he would work really
well
so that's how it happened oh it was that
simple all right he said yes we would
love to have him and he was there a
couple days later
how were his acting chops
I mean look you can you know he's he's
still bummed out that that they made him
say a line that he didn't like what was
the line
there's a flag on the play
uh
um Let me let me let me reintroduce you
here he's uh he played Kevin Malone on
the office he's a Brian Baumgardner I'm
a best you don't talk about the office
I'm a best-selling author
Mega podcaster award-winning all right
yeah okay yeah well why didn't you tell
fritzy that because fritzy gave me this
this sheet here and that he doesn't
listen to me it just says actor played
Kevin on the office that's all yeah
he doesn't listen to me uh and and the
show is still doing uh unbelievably well
we we played an episode we played the
chili episode yesterday
because it's it's just it's iconic it's
it's one of those one of the best scenes
in sitcom history is when you bring your
chili and oh God if I'm in a bad mood
all I need to do is put that on and
Kevin makes me laugh that's that's very
very kind of you Dan I you know I wish
we were here under better circumstances
I heard
uh I heard you were talking about it yes
at least this was attributed to you
totally randomly last night someone
brought you up and I didn't even know at
that moment that I was gonna be on your
show and said they were listening to you
yesterday and you just talked about as a
sports fan it's just
it doesn't matter what who you're
rooting for or against It's just sad
like a loss Brian it feels like a loss
it's Sports depression because I didn't
I'm not rooting for the Jets I mean I I
just root for story lines but that was a
storyline that we had been fed for
months and it just happened
too soon it was like wait a minute hold
on and the high of the highest of highs
when Rogers comes out and carrying the
flag spotlights on him and you're like
this is this is out of Central Casting
and and then four plays in and you know
who reached out to me right away as soon
as Rogers goes down the actor Josh dumel
and he goes Achilles
and I'm going well that soon too soon
you go no it's Achilles
and then I thought okay and then we're
texting back and forth myself and the
Dan Edison we're speculating here I
think when Rogers got up sat back down I
think he was asked is he doing okay and
he went nope and then I realized he has
blown out his Achilles tendon
crazy
it's just so sad yeah it is yeah and
it's like it doesn't matter Bo Jackson
is a was a sports depression because I'm
not a Raider fan but Bo Jackson
shouldn't go out that way where he gets
tackled in a game against the Bengals
and that's the last we ever see of Beau
as a football player so yeah that Sports
depression certainly set in uh it
doesn't happen often but that those are
certainly those visceral moments where
you're like oh my God this is yeah rough
how's the podcast are you allowed to
talk about the podcast I'm allowed to
talk about the podcast yes okay I am all
right uh off off the beat it's it's
great I mean we're having some trouble
because we're having trouble uh we're
we're actually speaking to a lot of
sports people now more than normal
because you know of the strike going on
and we can't it's difficult to have
actors on and uh you know hopefully that
gets resolved soon and we get back um we
get back to business but I'm I'm I'm
just loving it I'm I I I I I couldn't
love it more the conversations that
we're having and just had uh just had
Lindsey Vaughn on the podcast and Andrew
Whitworth and uh a host of a host of
others it's been AJ Brzezinski I don't
know if you've heard his new uh foul
territory thing it's amazing anyway it's
it's been it's been great Dan I
appreciate it I I um
uh yeah it's just been a hard hard
couple of days hard couple of days well
hard couple of months with what's going
on with the writers strike there as well
well yes yeah yeah that's for sure I I I
I knew when I think it was
I think it was like August 1st this
might be totally wrong and they canceled
the Emmys
which is in the third week of September
I went
well that doesn't sound good no at all
no by the way Will Ferrell went with us
to Dublin uh I saw why where was my
invite well I that was Year One
and and will is he he was the one who
kept pushing for us to go to Dublin for
a decade he's a he's a the founding
father of this okay I think we're going
to Dublin next year or okay we might go
to London to go to a Premier League game
I like the way you said that by the way
thank you Premiere thank you
um so I I will put on put out a soft
invitation to you okay let me know let
me know that's it it looked like a lot
of fun it looked like a lot of fun he
was he just said I'm not a guest I'm a
Danette I don't just whatever the danets
do we're doing and uh we hit the pubs
the pubs hit back but will was there and
then he flew so he flies on his own dime
and then yeah fly back on Friday because
his dad's birthday is Saturday in L.A
but he went over on Tuesday and stayed
till Friday morning and then went back
so
it's pretty awesome I will I will tell
you this I had the Good Fortune uh of
working with him getting to know him a
little bit and there is no joke I don't
know if you've ever heard this before
I don't know if they've ever spoken
about it but to those of us on the
outside
there is a a fierce competition between
Will Ferrell and Steve Carell on who is
the nicest guy in Hollywood
so we should have a nice off
you yes I pitched you the idea a nice
off a nice song yes and I'll be there to
be snarky oh you'll be the host you'll
be the host because you work with both
on the office yes yeah the nice off
between a nice off I like that uh hey uh
hopefully we'll have you on here uh
after the strike and good luck with the
podcast and uh thanks again for joining
us thanks Dan I appreciate it that's
that's uh Kevin from the office he's
been in a variety of things he's got a
podcast out Brian Baumgartner